hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
for Monday
uh October 3rd
2022. what's going on how are ya
oh I am having a [ __ ] day I'm having
a day while trying to be spiritual
well just noticing that a light went out
and my [ __ ] bedroom here that I have
to fix
you know I'm having one of these these
you know I made a list I have a bunch of
stuff I have to do today you know what
I'm gonna do I'm Gonna Make a list and
I'm gonna knock it out I like making a
list because as you knock it out it
makes you feel like you're accomplishing
something rather than looking at
everything that you have in front of you
right so I wake up this morning and I
make some [ __ ] you know
I say to my kids what do you want and
they're like pancakes I said pancakes
they're like yeah right
oh it's funny my son too
he has a Snoop Dogg shirt that he got
from uh passed down to him I hand him
hand me down from his sister
he saw it he's like Snoop I go yeah I go
Snoop Dogg he goes Snoop Dogg I go Uncle
Snoop and he's like you couldn't say
uncle he's like ah Snoop and I'm like I
go Uncle he goes Uncle I go Snoop and he
goes Snoop I go Uncle Snoop and he goes
Apple Snoop
[Laughter]
anyway
so my day's obviously going great you
know they're already cracking me up I go
downstairs
and uh I ask them I go okay what do you
guys want for breakfast and they said
pancakes I go you want healthy pancakes
you want yummy pancakes and they were
like yummy pancakes so I say all right
so go to the cupboard there's not enough
Bisquick so I go I gotta call the
[ __ ] audible here yummy pancakes no
problem right but that was the
foreshadowing
if this was like a movie there would
have been like you know when I went in
to look at the Box there'd be like a
weird little flutter of music
and then I would hear a noise and like I
don't know whatever the [ __ ] laundry
room
and then I'd be like what was that and
then you just see like a cat running
away like oh it's just a cat
it's not that there's an ex-murder in
the next 90 minutes
of this movie are going to be horrific
so anyway
um
I take my daughter to school and then I
had to swing by the bank to get some
cash for the [ __ ] week because I like
walking around with the [ __ ] gauge
actually I don't but I I just didn't
have any cash and I
go to the airport all the time and then
I go to tip somebody and I don't have
any [ __ ] money so then I gotta run
into the house or go stop at this ATM so
it's like gonna get organized
all right because this weekend I'm going
to Windsor Minnesota and Des Moines Iowa
Ottawa Iowa Iowa right
so I'm like why don't I get that out of
the [ __ ] way so what do I do I go to
the ATM they don't have any [ __ ]
money because it's the weekend right and
everybody's like I need more smack right
so they go to the [ __ ] ATM so there's
no more Goddamn money
so I was like all right no big deal
they'll [ __ ] I'm sure the Brinks
truck comes you know I'll I'll put this
at the end of the list
and then my truck is leaking oil it
needs new gaskets on either side of the
transmission so the guy tells me to
bring it by the [ __ ] place he's going
to pull the transmission and then
they'll bring the transmission over to
the [ __ ] guy so I get there
all right
and I'm driving behind this really slow
guy for no [ __ ] reason which means
he's Uber driving he has nowhere to go
and he's trying to stay in that general
area because he likes the clientele I'm
convinced that's what happens
you know they're constantly like
touching their cell phone that they have
mounted up on the dashboard
so I'm dropped behind this guy for three
excruciating miles where he makes no
lights
no lights and it's like ridiculously
careful like these two fire engines went
by I mean he let them go nine football
fields before he started driving again
is if he was somehow gonna I don't know
what
rear end one of them from [ __ ] three
stadiums away
you know I'm sure this guy wasn't doing
any of that
you know I bet he's a philanthropist and
does stuff under the privileged kids but
I'm late so I'm building this narrative
for this person
so you have you get behind somebody
[ __ ] slow like that and you just
right as you know you're coming up to
make you left you just know it you pray
to the [ __ ] Automotive gods that the
[ __ ] isn't going to make a left of
course he does and then you make the
left after he misses another light and
you're like I want to be in the left
lane not the right line don't be in the
[ __ ] left lane don't be in the left
lane don't be in the left lane and he
went to the right lane thing thank God
so I [ __ ] get by the guy
I go down to the garage it's a little
garage where they work on these old cars
and it's just jam-packed with people
there's some sweet old lady in front of
me for some reason she won't pull into
the driveway she stops on the street and
gets out of her car so now I'm behind
her
and I'm like what the [ __ ] and I'm
waiting for explained it was funny she
was like you know like jutting her head
around trying to make the noise that her
car was making
and then this little [ __ ]
[ __ ]
goes around both of us and just drives
in
just went around her right no respect
I'm sitting there I got turn signal on
you know where the [ __ ] I'm going just
drove around and then got out of the car
then you have the [ __ ] decency to
look over like they just made a [ __ ]
slick douche move
and she gets out and just starts talking
to him so I found then I drive around I
finally get in
and I'm looking at and it's just one of
these you know one of these moments
where you just can't you can't say
anything you can't say anything because
of cell phone cameras and she's a
[ __ ] woman so I can't say excuse me
you squat little [ __ ] you're gonna sit
there and [ __ ] act like you didn't
see the goddamn line and you're just
gonna go around it you know it's like
when you're at the [ __ ] Airport
and all of these [ __ ] [ __ ] like
like when you fly Southwest
there's literally it's a numbered system
it's it's [ __ ] simple genius and
these [ __ ] people act like they don't
get it like they don't get it and they
put you in this [ __ ] position so
here's the thing I mean what was I gonna
say to her
what the [ __ ] can I say to her because I
you know and she pulls out the cell
phone camera he's being toxic aggressive
male masculinity CIS [ __ ] whatever
and I I so I gotta [ __ ] eat that
I got you know I I slammed the door
really hard she doesn't give a [ __ ] she
doesn't [ __ ] hear it and I just
probably [ __ ] my door up it's something
else I have to get fixed
so I'm losing
big time on this day so then I [ __ ]
get there the guy says he can pull the
transmission he goes how are you going
to get it over there
I go you guys can't bring it over
he goes no I I can't bring it over I go
well can the people
that are going to fix it can they come
and pick it up
he's like I don't know and I'm like you
gave me that number
like what the it's a [ __ ] pickup
truck this is the vehicle I have to
bring it over
if you take it out I can't bring it up
[ __ ]
and I was so pissed at that woman I just
said [ __ ] it forget it I go you don't
have room for this thing anyways I just
got in what I should have done was been
[ __ ] relaxing like listen just pull
the thing I'll figure it out worst case
scenario I'll rent one of those U-Haul
trucks for 19.99 those pickups and I'll
drive the [ __ ] thing over there
I don't know
and then on the way back I was gonna
have the truck dropped off
be in the Uber and practice my French
because I've been [ __ ] killing it you
know I'm doing all right right
um
my daughter's learning her she has like
no accent it's [ __ ] unbelievable
I was asking something like uh
was it yes
or something like that and she was like
two
and I was like two she's like two oh my
God I'm saying like the number
and I was like wow man she has all that
like that whole like you know
the whole Community it's [ __ ] sounds
all down and everything she gets stuck
in there like it's really amazing
so
um
I was going to do that that was out the
[ __ ] window so I just went oh for
three
over three and um
you know so then you know you're pissed
and I'm thinking to myself well who can
I call right now and just dump this on
and I went through the Rolodex I'm like
well I can't do it to my wife you know
she lives with me and she hears it all
the time so I'm not doing that to her
I called A buddy of mine he didn't pick
up I'm like I'm glad he didn't pick up
because I'd ruined his morning and I was
just like oh wait a minute I have a
[ __ ] podcast
I'll dump it on you guys
[Music]
oh my God
I'm so happy though I didn't say
anything to that woman you know
maybe she didn't notice maybe that's
what you're supposed to do
I don't know am I an idiot like was I
was supposed to back up and drive around
the old lady's car I was gonna do that
to her
and if I did I would have missed her
trying to make the noise I think the
thing was lurching forward or something
maybe she had a stick I don't know what
it was like
um anyway so
that was my morning but I'm back on
track because right now I'm knocking
this out
you know I also went to the gym the last
three four days in a row I'm getting
back in shape you know uh the movie's
almost done so I have some free time
which is fantastic and
I did like three really really cool
cities this weekend I was in Louisville
Kentucky Bloomington Indiana and
Cincinnati Ohio
and um
just all three were absolutely
incredible crowds and I had so much fun
um
performing at all of them
Louisville I swear to God I could retire
there there's just something about the
pace that
that's like another one Chattanooga
Tennessee
all right uh
Milwaukee Wisconsin Louisville Kentucky
it's like it's the perfect you know
there's a city there's an art scene
there's food going on but there's not a
million [ __ ]
and because there isn't you probably
can't get a direct flight to a lot of
places but who gives a [ __ ] because who
wants to spend their life on an airplane
you know
so
um
anyway we go there
oh here's another thing that [ __ ]
happened was I I downloaded the new
stupid ass operating system for this
goddamn [ __ ] phone
and now you know I always send like
voice texts
you know that way like there's no
misunderstanding of your tone or
whatever and you can make somebody laugh
and you know as of yesterday I knew how
to do that I now don't know how to do it
anymore
so now I just send I'm just going to
start sending those texts that those
voice memo things I'm just sending those
now because I'm not gonna waste my time
learning how to do the new [ __ ] thing
just to have them change it again and
fill up my [ __ ] phone
um
I just don't understand like why they
have to change it every time what the
[ __ ] you know why for money to fill up
your phone so you have to buy the next
one what was wrong with the other one
why do I need a camera that's even
clearer
like now they're showing like the
commercial for the new iPhone they're
showing a guy shooting an action movie
on the phone it's just like this just
the average Joe
you know
shooting a video of his kid getting hit
in the nuts with a wiffle ball bat need
to [ __ ] be on the same level as Matt
and Scorsese
um it's really uh it's Overkill
I don't know
I'll be honest with you I was fine with
the flip phone
it was [ __ ] amazing
it kind of sucked because then people
could call me but hey I called you you
didn't pick up how come you didn't pick
up
you know I I missed that
that sort of uh
you know like whenever they have those
space movies there's that part you know
where they're re-entering this there's a
moment where they won't be able to
communicate with them we used to have
that
it's called like going to work going to
school
going out
where you going I'm going out that was
it
that was it and you didn't have to talk
to anybody in your [ __ ] life you
didn't want to
for hours
you know
if you would like some one of these
[ __ ] made men guys with your own
secretary
I guess they call them Mad Men now those
advertising guys but if you're one of
those [ __ ] people man like and you
had like a secretary you could literally
have your secretary
that you were probably banging screen
your calls
speaking of that secretary you're
probably banging you guys ever see that
Jack Lemmon movie the apartment
um
incredible movie that still holds up
it's like 60 years old 62 years old now
at this point and
um
and when you watch that movie you
realize like nothing has changed
as far as like human behavior and just
[ __ ] to people because I watched that
back then I'm like like I thought like
all [ __ ] around and being an idiot
and doing drugs and just
you know doing all that dumb [ __ ] that
you see adults doing nowadays
or I mean not my whole life basically I
thought that that started at like
Woodstock like they what the way they
they like frame [ __ ]
um
with like movies and stuff and the way
that they retell history there's like so
much [ __ ] that just is not
like accurate like to say the sexual
Revolution happened in the 1960s and
then you you're like you read to what
the [ __ ] they would do they were doing
during the Roman Empire
that like you know some that [ __ ] like
some of the [ __ ] they were doing back
then you would have to only be on the
dark web
um
what is my point
my point is is if you blow up a building
don't slowly walk away while not looking
at it
you know
uh what are some of the other things
like all that [ __ ] that like defies
physics
that and after a while you just see it
enough times it becomes like a law
like I was I was told what the [ __ ] was
I talking to I was talking to my wife
last night
and she brought something up and I
laughed and I was going you know that
isn't actually true that's just we've
seen it in movies enough times that now
we just sort of subconsciously
um
oh God what is this text message that I
just [ __ ] something up
oh okay
oh my God I have a guest coming up
I have two guests coming up on my
Thursday podcast that are two of my
favorite people in this business that's
called the teaser people when you're in
Show Business what you learn to do is
you don't give all the information like
I saw this guy you know now you know
after 53 in three quarter years I start
drinking coffee right
and I love it
by the way I got an incredible cup when
I was in Louisville
might have been the best cup I've ever
gotten
um
[ __ ] now I gotta find the name of it now
that I said oh [ __ ] it you'll figure it
out I [ __ ] it being with an S I think
um
and then I went to this place Hopscotch
in uh Bloomington Indiana that was great
I got the best burger I might maybe
possibly the best burger I've ever had
in my life at this place Bob's Burgers
and ice cream in Bloomington Indiana in
Louisville I also I went to the
Louisville Slugger Museum had like a
Make-a-Wish weekend right
and they gave us a private tour and they
brought us in to where all these the
prototypes for all these Hall of Fame
baseball players
bats were
and I was there with bartnick and he
said Mickey Mantle first and the first
is [ __ ] hilarious the first name I
thought of was George Foster from The
Big Red Machine who hit like 54 home
runs or 53 home runs in 1977.
and um you have to have gloves on they
don't want the oil from your hands or
anything to mess with the Bots and
um
it was everybody's bat felt like a bat
except for Ted Williams where uh
bartnick was saying it just felt like a
piece of lumber
which it was like he tore off like a
banister and just started you know
hitting 400 and climbing clubbing home
runs
um no wonder he still hit hit one the
farthest I think that's ever happened at
Fenway
that was swinging a [ __ ] telephone
pole
um
so anyway we did that we drove over to
Bloomington Indiana and then we the only
place to get something to eat was right
behind our hotel
it was this place called Bob's Burgers
and the first bite I was like oh my God
it had like this Smoky Char and a crust
on the outside and then was like softer
on the inside because I got it medium
rare but it was it wasn't like you know
a lot of people are doing that now you
know you get the crispy edges or
whatever this thing the whole thing on
the outside was crispy and it was like a
big one like
you know like you when your mother or
your dad would make a burger
um
the big ugly I got the half ugly
the uh the half pound one it was [ __ ]
delicious it was so good I went back
there the next day
um
and uh just had a great time and then we
played we played Assembly Hall
which is where the great Bobby Knight
coached him to uh three titles
one in the 70s two in the 80s
and uh I went there in in 2000 the 99
2000 year and I saw Indiana beat
Michigan State in a word time
um
I got to perform there with bartner Camp
too we were just sitting there like
cheesing ear to ear just couldn't
[ __ ] believe I couldn't believe that
I was there right and
[Music]
um
and then they treated me great I'll come
back anytime you want to go to a game
they gave me
um
some Indiana Hoosier gear it's now of
course I'm like I'm gonna [ __ ] watch
Indiana this year [ __ ] it
um
and the next day when we woke up uh for
our workout we walked from the hotel
over the campus and walked around the
football stadium we were hoping maybe we
could get in there but uh it wasn't open
like
every once in a while you'll go to one
of these big programs in the [ __ ]
stadiums open they just let the students
go in there and they can chill out or
run the stairs or whatever which I think
is cool that's how it used to be when I
was a kid
but um and then we went over to
Cincinnati
um speaking of George froster right
uh Riverfront Stadium which is no longer
there Great American Ballpark and
wherever the Bengals play whatever that
one's called and they were all psyched
because they uh beat the Dolphins
kind of beat him up I haven't seen the
play but somebody said it was a [ __ ]
cheap ass hit
um
you know somebody said to me you know
the San Antonio Brown's got to stop this
guy you know he's because I don't know I
guess he exposed himself or accused of
it or something and I was saying listen
man I go the guy he probably has CTE and
that [ __ ] Bengals hit that guy should
have been put in jail for that
I mean I don't know how he didn't take
his [ __ ] head off they basically
threw one high
and out of the way over the middle like
the Ultimate Nightmare
for a receiver
and this guy in the Bengals came by with
an old school like Oakland Raider from
the 1970s the sole Patrol
Scott Stevens shoulder to the [ __ ]
head
and uh I sent it to person I said this
is hard to watch but like I don't think
this guy's been the same since this hit
um and I got to give verzie credit he
was the guy the first guy who said when
Antonio Brown started acting a little
erratic was was saying that and
um
what I [ __ ] hate about it is
how many people just like look at that
behavior and they just take it at like
face value and they they get some sort
of perverse joy out of watching somebody
an elite athlete or something like that
like messing up their life
and then the same people when they
actually do the make for TV movie after
whatever tragic ending this seems like
it's going to have will then act like
you know
they weren't like staring at it and
joining they remember a long time ago
there was a [ __ ] celebrity that was
just [ __ ]
basically
you know on some hard drugs and was
tweeting and did all of this [ __ ] did
like a tour and all of that and
everybody was just going there to watch
the train wreck
remember like morning radio and
everybody like trying you know when
you'd call in they try to get you going
on it like hey what do you think about
that it's like I
I think it's terrible and I probably
imagined his parents and his
siblings are really worried about him
like
like what the [ __ ] are we doing here I'm
not kicking somebody when they're down
like that you know I like [ __ ] with
people that it's kind of doing all right
or whatever unless you do unless you I
don't know I shouldn't say that I
probably I've probably done it too
um
haven't I I'm sure you guys can give me
some examples of me doing it
no it Lord knows the ladies can
um
I saw a couple of good movies this
weekend too I saw uh
speaking I I saw uh
like just like the the middle of nowhere
and stuff
you know these out of the way places
that I that I [ __ ] love so much you
know as long as I'm in like the in town
area I feel like you go into the sticks
and you get these these [ __ ]
you know conspiracy theory racist
lunatics like I just I can't that's you
know it's so [ __ ] funny if you live
in a city you're around like
all these all like these different types
of people and because of that all these
different opinions
and
you know
you get this heightened sense of
humanity but you can't [ __ ] do
anything because everybody's on top of
each other then you get out in the
middle of nowhere and these people have
like this amazing like
peace and quiet if they want it
and this connection to Nature
that really helps reset your brain
but then like there could be like a clan
rally down the [ __ ] Street
ah this you can't have your cake and eat
it
you know that's that's basically what it
is you either [ __ ] live in the city
[ __ ] slowly go insane or uh you know
you gotta duck the clan coming up your
driveway scene if you want to make a
donation
it's probably a little extreme yeah
that's what I do on this podcast so
anyway I saw this movie called uh The
California Kid it was a made for TV
movie check it out it's on YouTube you
don't have to pay for it or nothing it's
an hour and 10 minutes
it stars uh Martin Sheen Vic Morrow
Morrow and uh Nick Nolte one of his
first roles and uh
you know it's the classic you know good
looking guy comes to town in a hot rod
gets pulled over by a corrupt Sheriff
gives him a [ __ ] ticket
the kid [ __ ] census there's something
going on in the town
and he starts to poke around and the
sheriff wants him out of town it's just
[ __ ] great
it's just a great great car movie
um and all of that stuff and then I also
saw I watched Steve McQueen and Ali
McGraw in uh the getaway
which was an amazingly shot movie uh
that I think by the guy who also did the
Wild Bunch
um like the beginning of the movies just
how they set up the whole movie
and they just kept stopping the film
and then they show you a little bit more
and they would stop the film or whatever
like I don't know why they did that I
was trying to think what the metaphor
was for it but it was really [ __ ]
amazing and uh
you know a bunch of great actors on that
one obviously uh and that was
essentially that was essentially my
weekend
you know I only had one cigar I've cut
back on that I went to the [ __ ] gym I
got I'm back on my ab
workout here my shoulder's feeling good
how many times have I said this probably
more times than I said I'm quitting
cigars
um
all right and then I got home in time
you know I took a 4 a.m pickup to get
home in time and I watched uh
you know I watched some of uh
what did I watch I watched the bills
Ravens
right up until the third quarter so I
missed the bills coming back then I had
to take my kid to a birthday party and
then I caught a little bit
the second half of uh Kansas City
versus uh the Buccaneers
um
yeah so I got to I got to watch a little
bit of football I saw a little bit of uh
the Michigan game too
I can't remember who the hell they were
playing because I also watched a little
bit of Indiana and Iowa
and Michigan was playing
because it's somebody in the Big Ten
it's October the games start to get a
little hotter
um all right I'm just babbling here
uh this weather podcast is great because
now I really don't give a [ __ ] about
what happened this morning and
everything I'll I'll figure it out
it always works out what is nobody gonna
fix the car bill eventually they'll fix
it it'll be fine all right uh butcher
box
let's do a little advertising here
butcher box there is no substitute for
free-range turkey without any
antibiotics antibiotics or home or
hormones
why was that so hard to say there is no
substitute for free-range turkey without
any antibiotics or hormones
I was saying hormones hormones but it's
not always easy to find luckily there's
butcher pucks the benefits of butcher
box Peace of Mind butcher box takes the
guesswork out of finding high quality
meat and seafood you can trust a hundred
percent grass-fed beef free-range
organic chicken pork uh raised crate
free and wild caught a seafood you don't
know what it's going to do humanely
raised no antibiotics or hormones
um
ultimate convenience get just what you
want delivered right to your doorstep
free shipping no [ __ ] standing in a
line and having some little squat [ __ ]
[ __ ] cut in front of you uh the squat
[ __ ]
uh on CBS free shipping free shipping
for the continental United States and no
surprise freeze choose from a variety of
box plan options from curating to
customize and change your plan whenever
you want incredible value enjoy a range
of high quality cuts that are hard to
come by at the grocery store and an
amazing amazing value the main course
for Thanksgiving dinner can be a main
source of stress not anymore butcher box
is offering our listeners free turkey
with their first order yeah and it's
hormone antibiotic free so you know
you're not poisoning your loved ones or
maybe uh you don't like a lot of people
at Thanksgiving maybe you want to get
your turkey somewhere else I don't know
but if you love your family butcher box
is for you sign up today at
butcherbox.com
to get 10 to 14
to get one 10 to 14 pound turkey free in
your first box
look at that the butcher uh that's
butcherbox.com use code Burr b-u-r-r to
clean this deal
um all right
nextly
it's not even a word
uh Roman Roman is the digital Health
Clinic digital health clinic for [ __ ]
God damn man
it's the Schaefer song Sorry Roman is
the digital health clinic for men there
are no waiting rooms and no hassle just
a straightforward and discreet digital
experience all from the comfort of your
own home to achieve your health care
goals get started by completing a free
online visit a U.S licensed health care
professional will work with you to find
the best treatment plan if medication is
appropriate Roman ships it to you
directly in a discrete packaging for
free with free two-day shipping right
now Roman has an offer for our listeners
generic
Viagra
generic just regular old make that dick
stand up and get the job done a [ __ ]
straight six easy to work on AKA
sold
the fill s-i-l-d-e
it would be slide if the L was the other
way around is the I still long
no you can't because as an elder silda
nephil sildenafil
AKA sildenafil is just four dollars a
post uh per dose
oh my God four dollar hooker uh four
dollars that's less than a cup of coffee
four dollars oh I'm so says question
mark four dollars that's less than a
magazine at the newsstand just go to get
roman.com
today that's get roman.com AKA
sildenafil
they're hard [ __ ] names just uh for
just four dollars per dose
it's Christ my [ __ ] brain needs a
tune-up he should have pulled my brain
down there and switched out the gaskets
all right here we go somebody talking to
me the way I want them to talk to me
talking about the [ __ ] that I care loud
stadiums all right to do a recap I went
to the Arizona Cardinals game and it was
one of the loudest stadiums I've ever
been to but it wasn't the fans
the fans were regular it was the sound
system I essentially had two Marshall
Stacks pointed at me and it was like
Randy Rhodes Mick Moz and Eddie Van
Halen were all playing at the same time
like the sound system was literally
taking the crowd out of the game
um and I was bitching I was just like
maybe I'm just too [ __ ] old I have no
idea it says Bill you're not an old man
when it comes to loud stadiums it's as
you would say horrific I hate going to
basketball games now and they and they
used to be my favorite I hate every
music choice and even if I like the song
I wouldn't want to hear it here three
and a half seconds of it while the ref
walks the ball a few feet
yeah that's so bizarre like you just
can't have
a moment
of people just talking about the game it
literally takes the crowd out of the
game there's like no personality in the
stands no feeling of like wow I'm in
Cincinnati I'm in Bloomington Louisville
like the tour I just did you would hear
different accents you'd hear different
[ __ ] you'd hear Sports history heckles
from games that went past
and now you can't hear any of it because
there's some DJ playing the same five
songs
all right no one likes this except
losers who want to feel like they're at
the club
I really think I don't even think it's
sad I don't think that people had that
choice I think that they
um
I think that it's just an algorithm
they're like everybody's walking
you're out of here sorry everybody's
walking around with their whole [ __ ]
music collection in their pocket these
kids you know with these devices we
gotta
you know
I think once again it's
they're trying to react to something and
they're not doing it the proper way like
I remember
um
somewhere in the late 80s early 90s
that whole quick cutting everything
quick cut quick cut you know everything
you saw cut cut cut cut different shot
different shot they started shooting
movies and TV shows like that because
they were like because they couldn't get
people to stay on the channels because
they had so many options and people were
channel surfing and they weren't
watching and they weren't watching the
commercials so they weren't making as
much money so they thought that if they
did a bunch of edits it would give you
the visual experience of changing the
channel and that would make you
not change the channel
okay now I've said that out loud that
sounds pretty stupid right like because
you're doing all these Quick Cuts I
don't notice that I'm watching the same
actors and it's the same TV show or
movie it was [ __ ] dumb but that's
what they did and I think with
[Music]
um
these sound systems
I I don't know what they're doing
because they they it should be illegal
to be doing that or at least without
warning people to bring earplugs to the
games because people are going to get
tinnitus
um
you know whatever keep going there you
know it's too loud you're too old man
you don't want to end up like me with a
ring in your ear that never stops until
you [ __ ] die uh no one likes this
except losers who want to feel like
they're at the club it has nothing to do
with the sport outdoor football stadiums
in the cold and some ballparks on a
summer day are acceptable I don't think
so dude
I think the crowd should be making the
noise and if you're not
I don't think it's a way of the owners
hiding the fact that they don't have a
good product
and it just sounds loud
you know even though it doesn't deserve
to be loud because they're not playing
well
he said hockey is getting to be bad too
tennis and golf are pure pool and
billiards are probably fine too pool and
billiards are not Sports
um golf is not a sports all of those are
activities tennis is a sport you're
competing against someone else who's
trying to stop you none of this [ __ ]
you're competing get your mind I'm not
getting one on that [ __ ] rant anymore
anyway it's just tennis is golf for
athletes
foreign
it's just another way in which TV and
media represent what the public wants
less and less these days yeah yet while
still dictating it because the mouth
breathing morons will listen and they
can still move the hurt
oh wow bill that was like a dystopian
tale of deepness you dumb [ __ ] sorry all
right Punk kids
dear bill
my kid is nine year nine years old and
attends a good public school one thing
that has changed since I was a kid is
that kids are way more entitled to
Authority than in the 80s yeah once
again because they're cell phone cameras
they can't get smacked
um
I'm amazed at how little
you know what the new superhero should
be somebody
that when somebody deserves to get
slapped and you can't the superhero
arrives and I used to think well as the
superhero comes and arrives and slaps
the offender for you and leaves but
that's like a [ __ ] move because you
should do it yourself and then if the
person fights back you should be able to
handle it so I think that the
superheroes should come there and has
the ability to knock out all the cameras
like put them on pause
and then he just looks at you and says
all right go ahead you know you want to
hit this guy go ahead
let's get it on like Mills Lane comes
back right
superhero Mills Lane rest his soul he
comes back and when he shows up because
of the Shine off his bald head like mine
it blocks all the cameras are you ready
are you ready let's get it on right and
then you [ __ ] walk up to the person
that cuts you in the line and you just
slap him across the face and then they
can be horrified or they can react you
can win you can lose just like the old
days
and then when it's over it's over you're
done you give it's up that's it Mills
Lane flies away the shines off his head
you know and both people limp away
um anyway
uh this person continues and says I'm
amazed at how little say the adults in
their lives have my kid brings it home
too occasionally she was doing something
she shouldn't have been she shouldn't
have been doing and instead of being
slightly ashamed of their clearly wrong
Behavior she started saying that I
wasn't acknowledging her feelings on the
matter
oh God that's psychological [ __ ]
uh we sat down with their mother and
talked about it she explained that her
teacher gave examples of when it's okay
to talk back to your parents or
authority figures
when your feelings are being ignored
she used words like emotional
manipulation
oh my God
she told your kid that
we had to explain that we always want to
hear her feelings on things but her
feelings on something don't overrule
what's right or wrong wow killer [ __ ]
answer can I take that
yeah because I'm having that right now
my daughter uh with her iPad like I'm
I'm done with that [ __ ] thing and she
can't handle it's like you're not gonna
spend your childhood
you know staring at this thing and she
gets mad and then we go outside we have
a great time like uh we went out to you
know out to the garage where they got
all their bikes and stuff and she still
likes messing around on the balance bike
and I couldn't get my son to do it so
um
you know she got on the bounce bike and
she was doing it and that's that's it
it's over once once the little kid sees
the bigger kid doing it you know they
want to do it too so now my son loves
the balance bike and he kept calling it
his motorcycle
so I'm going out there with that kid
every single day
until he uh he gets it down
and then they're going to be able to
ride bikes together
it's going to be [ __ ] great hopefully
my truck will be finished you know
I can take him somewhere to ride their
bikes or up and down the driveway
you know I'm Gonna Keep playing catch
with them
you know I still underhand the ball they
got no none of that t-ball [ __ ] they got
to hit it that way like all of that
stuff that they're getting t-ball
I don't know I didn't like a balance
bike now I like a bounce back maybe
t-ball is good for a minute then after a
while it's like eventually you know this
isn't golf
it's a sport okay someone's gonna try to
get the ball past you
sorry
um I actually really enjoy golf but I
think it's a great
activity uh my kids
um so I'm gonna say this again for other
parents out there we had to explain that
we always want to hear feelings on
things but her feelings on something
don't overrule what's right and wrong
but when you ended and died what's right
and wrong
uh my daughter is a sweet kid and always
owned up to when she did things wrong
something me and my wife were always
proud of yeah
I'm not one of those psychos that needs
to control everything that goes on at my
kid's school but how about a little
respect for the real world I heard one
of her friends say that that another
kid's parents were toxic and negative
because they wouldn't let her their
nine-year-old daughter go to a co-ed
sleepover that wasn't that was
supposedly supervised give me a [ __ ]
break every kid I knew growing up would
be more than willing to rob a
convenience store
then even suggest that to a parent
what that it was
that they want to go to a co-ed
sleepover or that they were being toxic
in heaven listen we're on the same page
and I'm assuming you're younger than me
even though your kid's older than mine
because I started so late so that's good
to know that younger people still feel
that yeah [ __ ] all this [ __ ]
all of that [ __ ] that like
um
these beta social media liberals what
they've done
is you know
I guess they wanted to make the world
better but then they just immediately
took that power and now it's like you
can't say anything like I couldn't say
anything to that woman today
that went around the line
that she was a selfish [ __ ] back in the
day you could be your [ __ ] selfish
[ __ ]
you don't see the line
you know you could say [ __ ] like that
you can't say it anymore now you have to
be like excuse me did you I mean
I mean I mean those words exist for a
reason
you can call a man a [ __ ] too I wouldn't
call her a [ __ ] I would have been like
yeah but I would have dropped been
dropped some f-bombs like hey excuse me
I might you don't see the [ __ ] line
you just drive around you think you're
better than it is but this is the thing
about that you could never you can never
win an argument with a woman you just
can't win an argument with a woman
so you don't argue with them that's how
you win that is the only way to win an
argument with the woman
okay you can win temporarily by beating
the [ __ ] out of them but then you go to
jail right
[ __ ] with you um you can't you just
can't win so how you win
is if you're wrong you say you're right
and you apologize if you're right you
can't keep arguing like if a woman's
right with the man they can keep arguing
and then you're like all right you're
right
but if you're right they're not gonna
[ __ ] give up
they just did like they're [ __ ]
Badgers they Wolverines they just they
they don't give up right varmints so
what you got to do is
you you don't argue with them
if you say you did this this and this
and then they say you know and it made
me feel like this and then they say no I
didn't oh well you should have done that
you just go oh
all right
and then that's it
that's it
you just walk away
and then they know
they know they know they're [ __ ]
wrong
so then they're going to come down and
try to talk to you to try to feel you
out and the big thing there is don't be
an [ __ ] to them because if you're an
[ __ ] then they'll use that
that you're being an [ __ ] and then
the argument becomes about that don't be
an [ __ ] to them don't be overly nice
because then they won't apologize just
be [ __ ] neutral
just be neutral that's the only way
that's the only way so with that woman
who did that [ __ ] we don't have a
relationship we don't have the time
and you can no longer call a [ __ ] a [ __ ]
so you just have to let it go and
hopefully you have a podcast
so I'm actually proud of me me for not
saying that oh man I [ __ ] said it
I [ __ ] said it
I said it in the truck a whole bunch of
[ __ ] times
uh when I drove away what a national I
should lift my truck there and [ __ ]
had a cooler head but that's not the way
I'm wired anyway uh if the dollar goes
digital
um hey Bill there's talk of the US
adopting a completely digital Dollar in
the next 10 years or so I was wondering
how you would react to having to use
completely digital money
all the time
uh also there's a clip that's going
around where a fat Italian man from a
bank is saying that they'll be able to
control how people spend their money
would you adopt this new dollar or wrap
the phone cord around your neck and make
the jump
I mean
um yeah you can't fight any of this
you can't fight it is all of this stuff
is going to happen
and they're just going to keep
speaking of the Court around your neck
they're going to keep yanking it Tighter
and Tighter and Tighter and Tighter
until someday somebody way smarter than
me
takes out like
a 1200 to 1200 people that are doing
this to everybody else
until somebody does that but the bottom
line is everybody wants to join the club
and everybody gets paid by the club
that's why these people who are wrapped
up
in red ties and blue ties and actually
think that it makes a difference
and actually think that these people are
there for you and actually think that
they're public servants they are not
public servants they are private
servants
and they work for those 1200 or whatever
there is they work for those people
they work for the people that literally
uh
dump [ __ ] into the water supply if you
and I dump [ __ ] to a water supply we are
[ __ ] terrorists and we are going to
jail for the rest of our lives they do
it they pay a fine they don't clean up
the government makes us pay for it
because those are the people those
[ __ ] [ __ ] are the ones that sign
their goddamn checks and every once in a
while you have a politician who will
actually try and stand up against those
[ __ ] and that person is immediately
labeled a communist or a socialist
and
for whatever reason liberals and
conservatives
you know people that are loyal to those
parties believe it
I mean you look at Bernie Sanders in the
[ __ ] that that guy wanted to do like the
Democrats literally boxed that guy out
and gave the nomination to Hillary
Clinton they've done it to him twice
and the Liberals on the left spoke and
said this is the person we want and they
[ __ ] ignored it because all of them
are on the [ __ ] take just like all
the ones on the right are on the take
probably except for a few a handful of
them so that's basically what it is
you know it is what it is what the [ __ ]
are you gonna do
um
you know
whoever organizes the thing someday
who's way smarter and knows how to do it
I will join that to try and fight it but
until they do I'm not going on a Reddit
page and just sit there talking about
gloom and doom with a bunch of other
people with no [ __ ] Solutions because
you slowly go insane
so uh
you know I think the only way to combat
this type of stuff is you really have to
work on yourself to become a better
person a more empathetic person and you
know as I'm sitting there telling some
somebody a squat [ __ ] on this [ __ ]
thing but like
um
you know all of this [ __ ] that they stir
up your feelings about other countries
or or or the racist that Trump stirs up
you know what I mean these [ __ ] like
just straight up people that walk around
saying the [ __ ] N word and [ __ ]
um
and like you really have to try
and not listen to those people and get
caught under their [ __ ] [ __ ]
because they're they're they're
they don't have your best interest and
you know Hillary Clinton I don't think
there was there's no difference
she's just as evil As Trump she's just
smarter
[Music]
she just knows how to say what she's
saying
um
you know but you know what she's doing
okay
look you know I don't want to get into
this [ __ ] but like
you know that [ __ ] that people are
saying online going hey so you got the
Epstein guy and you got the person that
booked the island but what about that
list of people of all the people that
went there
and they're protecting those people
and they got rid of the people that were
going to expose them I mean I mean it's
it's really not conspiracy theory it's
kind of right there if you want to see
it
um
yeah it's and you know liberals love
a guy that
I got to be careful I don't get in
trouble but like liberals love a guy
that like went there allegedly like 20
[ __ ] times they still love the guy
they they love a guy that drone bombed
weddings
so like I don't see them as liberal
Progressive [ __ ] people and then on
the right you know what they're showing
me is [ __ ]
toothless racist so I don't even know
where the [ __ ] I stand right now
but uh
uh you know they can't stop me from
enjoying my day and trying to be a nice
person and enjoying being a father
you know if that's what you want to do
you want to stick all my money on my
phone and [ __ ] control where I spend
it fine
does that make you happy does that make
you dick hard
I don't give a [ __ ] because life is
flying by
and all you can they can't you can't
stop time
you know
all you can do is enjoy yourself so just
don't be a [ __ ]
there's a [ __ ] line waiting it
[ __ ] [ __ ] all right
1970s commercials
um
hi Bill we are roughly the same age and
I figure in 1975 would be some of our
earliest memories of commercials and I
was right see how many of these things
ring your memory belt by the way I
listen to you on the treadmill at Planet
Fitness and I find it helps lower my
rage so thanks oh that's good that makes
me feel good I'm glad my anger helps out
your anger so am I supposed to sit there
and watch these commercials can I watch
this on my podcast is this interesting
all right here we go Fred fix presents
[Music]
wow that was a cologne commercial for
chicks perfume
[Music]
the sporty little four-seater you didn't
expect the moles I remember this
commercial
oh that's when American cars sucked that
was the old catalytic converter
standard four-speed shift can't get out
of its own [ __ ] way
will die at 60 000 miles
it's good to know this old says another
Oldsmobile what do we got here
oh my God a lot of little Oldsmobile
that's a good looking car probably
underpowered the Oldsmobile Omega yeah I
remember all of those things
uh 1975 was a great year
I love the 70s man
I had a great [ __ ] time you know
I was basically 10 and under the Whole
Decade so it was just all about you know
football cards
got a paper route I started making money
you know I had my first job
uh you know I didn't know football
players wore shoulder pads I thought
their shoulders were that big I mean it
was it was a great time
you know there was no tablets or any of
that [ __ ] you just went outside
and you played it was [ __ ] fantastic
um
I didn't realize the Vietnam War had
just ended I had no idea what the
Vietnam War was
I didn't know anything all I knew is
that riding bikes and I learned how to
throw a spiral
you know by myself by just throwing the
ball and going after it because that was
the 70s everybody was a [ __ ] latchkey
kid both your parents worked that's how
I learned how to throw a spiral by
myself
throwing to nobody
if that isn't 1975 I don't know what is
and I remember it spun and I was like I
couldn't believe it
I couldn't believe it and I ran inside
to tell my mom who was sleeping on the
couch because uh she worked the uh the
third shift
so she could watch us during the day
over the summer which she didn't really
she just was asleep on the couch
no
like her her parenting the poor thing
was she couldn't sleep in the bedroom
she had to sort of be where we were and
she would just send us outside and she
would sleep on the couch in the living
room
um all right overrated Technologies
uh Bill you've talked about overrated
Technologies in the past and I'd like to
submit my own candidate for this
category all streaming services I miss
cable TV it's so funny man when cable TV
came out everybody was just like this is
too many channels I missed when it was
just three channels and everybody
watched the local news not this new CNN
stuff
um
now people miss this I miss cable TV
lots of movies and weird [ __ ] to choose
from now channels can be boring and have
nothing on them because they just want
to give the illusion of things on TV
um
most of all I miss responsive remotes
analog ship bill is that what the
problem is when you push the button the
channel changed immediately no [ __ ]
menus I'm only 42 by the way so this is
an old man's [ __ ]
that's hilarious
um
is that what's going on
yeah I remember those big like
it's like that uh when you buy like
homemade butter or you buy like cream
cheese it was like the size of one of
those packages
remember you used to make like a big
noise when you the the original ones
um
yeah they were great I can still
remember it was like uh
it was like a purple brown was the
remote that we had
and uh there was a big thing with like
kids at school going like what movie
channels do you have
and uh the movie channel
was that was what Cinemax became when it
became skinamax
uh the movie channel was the one that
had the dirtiest movies and HBO and
Cinemax was sort of like the best movies
and then HBO pulled ahead
and then I think Cinemax was like well
we can't [ __ ] with HBO let's [ __ ] with
the movie channel and then they started
showing all the softcore porn
and became known as skinamax and
somewhere in there was Showtime
um
yep and MTV had just come out
you guys are making me feel good about
my childhood with this uh with these um
these emails this week because like it
was really I mean it was just like
like yesterday as a dead I had such a
great time because my kids were doing
the [ __ ] that I did when I was a kid
they weren't on the tablet and they were
having a [ __ ] blast
and they were riding around on their
bikes so the the balance bikes and [ __ ]
and like I was telling my wife and thank
God Nia is totally on board with that
it's like
like we're going to be like our kids
gonna be like outside kids like they're
going outside they're going to play
catch they're riding bikes you know I
got my drums they can mess around on uh
we're gonna go out to eat as a family
yeah you know we're gonna go to the move
like I can't wait till they're big
enough when we can just like go to the
movies if they weren't so [ __ ] loud
those things are too goddamn loud too
but um
just doing stuff like that as opposed to
like everybody's in the same room and me
and my wife are staring at the phone and
the kids are looking at the tablet or
watching the [ __ ] flat screen TV
um
I'm gonna make a point of uh
doing stuff like that because I remember
there was like little things that meant
a lot to me as a kid
to uh
just like family moments I remember like
once a week we would all go out to
dinner and we would go to McDonald's
[Laughter]
I think I told this before but I always
say that but I don't know
um we used to go to McDonald's
and I was living on the North Shore
Boston when I was a little kid
and um
I remember uh there was a couple of like
pro ball players that lived in and
around the town like Rico Petrocelli who
played uh shortstop for the Red Sox and
Kenny Hodge
great Kenny Hodge you play for the
Boston Bruins he was like a town over or
something like that you drive by the
house like that's Kenny Hodges house you
couldn't believe it and um it was just
McDonald's and it was by like a train
track like an elevated train track that
went over like this Viaduct and we would
sit there
and we would eat outside
and I don't you know all the kids got a
cheeseburger small fry and a chocolate
shake and then my parents would get
a Big Mac large fry
and uh they get a a Coke it was all it
was always the same order and we'd all
be excited we'd piling the station wagon
or I think we had a Buick Regal
like a 72 or 73 Buick Regal that we were
renting
from this place Bob Brest Buick
um I still I can't believe I remember
that [ __ ] I can't remember [ __ ] from
yesterday
and we would drive over to this
McDonald's
and in the summertime
we would get it and we would eat outside
on the little plastic tables and [ __ ]
and uh there would be like seagulls and
you could throw them like [ __ ] french
fries and [ __ ] and every once in a while
you'd go there and the train went by and
it was like the most amazing thing you
know when it goes by and it sort of
gliding by and then that Bell is ringing
and you'd be eating McDonald's and it
was the summer time when you were a kid
and you had a shirt on that had a number
on it nobody's name none of that
Mitchell in that [ __ ] it was just a
random shirt with a number on it it was
just like a couple of stars on the
sleeves and it was like the greatest
[ __ ] thing ever
um
yeah I'd like to have my kids have that
moment rather than being like
staring at a [ __ ] tablet playing
Minecraft whatever the [ __ ] that is
my kid just wants that thing so bad
um and I'm I have this crushing need to
be liked which is why I'm a comedian
um and I do what I do so I have to be
cognizant of that to not give into that
so my kid air quote likes me
um you want to talk about manipulation
getting back to that like I gotta watch
out for that last night like she was
just having like you know
a real hard time with it but I know
you know in the end
when she's grown up
hopefully she'll understand that as
she's talking to all her friends who are
going to be [ __ ] scatterbrained from
this uh overload of information
um so that's it people I want to bring
you know if I was a politician I'm gonna
I want to bring back playing catch with
you kids
foreign
I think it's a great way to connect with
them you know it's good for hand-eye
coordination
and uh
you know it's a big thing for a kid you
should know how to throw
you know know how to ride a bike know
how to throw know how to whistle the
little you know the little starter kit
of being a kid so you're not the kid
that doesn't know how to do it right
I don't know probably overcompensating
on some level anyway that is the podcast
look how [ __ ] relax damn I started
off calling somebody a squat little
[ __ ] steaming [ __ ] whatever the hell
I said and in the end of it I'm talking
about trying trying to be a good dad you
know there we go I think you know when
you really think about it everything
works though
um all right that is the podcast go [ __ ]
yourselves
especially that woman that just drove
around
um
oh whatever maybe she was right to do it
I bet her dad's proud that she's a
go-getter maybe she's a go-getter maybe
she's not a [ __ ]
hey you know what
ever you know how does that expression
go
hey one man's [ __ ] is another man's
go-getter
[Music]
and there you go we learned something
all right God bless her I bet she's nice
and she she'll find love and be a great
mom someday why does she have to be
attached to a man to get satisfaction in
life [ __ ] off see you Thursday